Yes
[Applause]
Welcome to El Hierro, the first
energy self-sufficient island in Europe.
I started working for
sustainability in El Hierro in
the early 90s, at that time when
we proposed a sustainable development program
that included areas such as
waste.  water, agriculture,
fishing, energy, etc., etc. And
we launched this sustainability project.
Water management on a
volcanic island like ours with a
very unstable rainfall regime is vital, which is
why we have a sustainable way
of managing water both from the
production of wells as well as
desalination, then with this system a
drop of water can go from the south to
the north or vice versa if indeed right
now we are precisely
raising water from the border area, which
is a system that is quite open to that
distribution
in the  hierro has opted for
sustainable fishing whose emblem or
most important project has been the creation of the
r  Mar de las Calmas marine reserve and
we believe that it has been a
successful initiative that allows the
sector as a whole to be carried out
by young people at this time, removing the
fishing gear that overexploits you catch less
fish than reproduces  and it is
totally sustainable
[Music]
the gorona del viento power plant I think
is the emblematic project of
sustainability in iron both for its
size and for its impact
together we achieve that a
variable source such as the wind
becomes a stable service
Combining wind and hydraulic energy
not only does not emit CO2
polluting products into the atmosphere,
but also allows
the money
that is paid each year for electricity to be recirculated within the local economy,
providing benefits for the elderly
for young people for clean
vehicles and  I think that this is a contribution that
all communities should try
because owning their own energy
means  would have a very important bone benefit
[Music]